[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits I'm Rhett and
I'm link this week at the roundtable of
dim lighting we have I'm pulling out a
word here that I rarely use right okay
I'm excited we have YouTube personality
powerhouse Wow that's right I guess a
powerhouse the one and only jenna
Marbles well I think she's justified of
being called a power house because she's
currently the number one female YouTube
personality I mean in the top she's in
the top three most subscribed YouTube
personalities period right when there's
a lot of companies up there but once you
once you take the companies out she's
the number three person over 13 million
subscribers over 1.5 billion views on
these videos she's been making for the
past few years okay now Jenna caught her
first viral break back in 2010 with a
video titled how to trick people into
thinking you're good-looking the video
currently has 57 million views and
Counting and after a six-month break
from YouTube which we'll get into
exactly why that happened she started
uploading weekly videos she's been doing
that for about the past four years a
recent example of that is things boys
don't understand part three this was got
three million views let me tell you have
you ever gone over to a girl's house
and like taking out her garbage well
I've done some dishes hello this is like
chivalry what you have swept me off my
feet a guy comes over my house and takes
out the garbage for me I'm sorry but I'm
pretty sure that's grounds for
eight-seat love love you want to move in
we'd be my roommate can I marry you okay
so you're in for a real treat this
conversation that we had with Jenna got
real we discussed her life before
YouTube including the dangers and
triumphs of go-go dancing yeah did you
know they were triumphs yeah there were
some okay
and what it's like to be pretty much the
most popular woman on the internet what
is it like to live the life of the most
popular woman on the Internet including
how she's managing her current romantic
relationship yeah we get it was like
he's like oh you want to go there yeah
yeah we did we went there so here it is
our ear biscuit with jenna Marbles okay
so you talked about something pretty
ironically coincidental that's kind of
using this a little redundant there in a
recent video your obsession with Google
Earth
Islands yep and I mean when you said I
just go on Google Earth and I zoom into
an island and then I hit the Wikipedia
thing I was like I didn't know about
anybody else did that yeah I have a an
obsession and shut up about Islands so
tell us about your island obsession I
don't know you just get in these dark
corners of like the ocean and you're
like I wonder what's over here and you
zoom in you're like ah there's a place
here and people that live here like it's
insane yeah and like you you start
thinking like okay I mean how these I
know they got like phones and like
electricity and stuff but you start
thinking like how are they connected to
the outside world and when am I gonna
get to go there I've never been to any
of them that's the most disappointing
thing have you know into one of these
islands no no never I don't even know if
you can get to some of them by like a
plane you have to fly to somewhere and
then take a weird boat another place a
really long skinny but I think Soyuz but
you were talking about how you'll sue
Minh and they'll be like a wiki entry no
yeah and then you can read about the
people that live there if there are
people there or if it's just like a
weird like label base for something and
about it you know about this one
I told you you remember I told you I got
obsessed with this island and I can't I
feel stupid that I can't remember the
name but it's off the coast of Mexico in
the Pacific Ocean it's one of the most
remote islands in the world nobody lives
on it now but back in the day like a
hundred years ago there were
a man who basically started his own like
little country and he had all these
women and they they were all in the
island because they were collecting bat
guano bat feces can be they can be used
for things and it's just it has this
toxic lake in the middle yes the kind of
place I want to go have you read the
wiki on this one no well now Google
Mexico way out into the Pacific there's
an island there weird stuff happened and
I'm down with that he'd be faster right
on my alley
you really find yourself on your phone
like zooming in on ocean space mm-hmm
that's like one of the one of your
things yeah big time I mean like is it
not yours like I don't understand how
people are not so curious the same thing
with space like I just can't get enough
of it like what do you mean you don't
know what's out there I need to know can
I google 800 conspiracy theories about
the universe sorry I'm gonna space I'm
gonna spend my time doing that think
about Google sweet Google space I think
no but it should be good zoom in on a
planet and hit the wiki thing but see
they have they don't know enough about
planets yet that's the problem well you
could do it and then just have that be
like your thing okay I just patented it
Google space works but you think about
these I don't know if the words
metaphysical or cosmetic type things
like Manik is not a word but you know
what I'm not medic is a word
cosmological is a word Jenna knew what I
meant as a child did you own a telescope
yeah I did actually
oh that's so out of the blue question it
goes into space yeah there's a miss base
this is true we had a lake house in
upstate New York my dad did and it was
like a little tiny little lake and we
were just you know super clear there's
no lights or anything out there and we
would just sit out there and stare at
the stars like I don't know like a whole
lot more than like any other eight year
old about stars but we just sit there
I'm like what do you think that is we
don't know a star a star with the
telescope with the telescope so what I
would use it to spy on the people across
the lake but I liked the Stars you
pointed it up and the moon really
yeah so you had the charts and stuff no
I don't have any of that we just had
telescope
my dad's a chemist so we were like a
little bit nerdy okay an actual chemist
yes
and you guys used to be engineers right
yeah we did look my brother's an
engineer oh yeah use the material
science engineer for Hewlett Packard in
Albany Oregon really mm-hmm material
science yeah I got an industrial
engineering degree civil engineering but
chemical I mean the chemistry 101 that
was I still have stress dreams about
that class oh man I still I have if I
have a stress dream about being back in
college and not being somewhere on time
is it Kim what L wanted yeah so you're
your father was his name or is mine
Thomas Thomas yeah he fostered this kind
of geekiness into you like here take
this telescope well Jenna
yeah just for like science and things
like that not so much math math was like
oh you know you get to math and you're
like we I don't want to do this I just
want to like put rocks and a rock
tumbler all day oh right boy Jenna this
is great you've really done it I opened
Pandora's box links thing thing is the
rock tumbler is it really yeah oh so you
didn't get that working you're like who
knew that jenna Marbles was the perfect
intersection of rhett and Link making
things about ourselves you have to do
these two on one interviews because we
have to outnumber the guests we've
talked about my rock tumbler experience
as a child on multiple he was obsessed
with the rock tumbler I had a telescope
I pointed it at my neighbor's house but
I also had a rock tumbler yeah the thing
was awesome it was boss it will come
with the rocks that you're supposed to
put it in the tumbler and then they come
on all shiny and they're like oh this is
great and then you know naturally as a
kid you're like well what else can I put
in the rock tumbler and so it's just all
your stuff ends up on the rock tumbler
yeah it just gets really weird no living
things good well that's cause you're a
girl yes I would have put a frog in
there
didn't have one so tell us more about
growing up Jenna
you had the you had the telescope in at
the lake house experience with your
brother and your dad it is that what you
lived like a summer house kind of thing
yeah was it the summer house kind of
thing and it was like an hour and a half
away from Rochester as I grew up in
upstate New York brutal winters really
snowy because we not only had you know
we're up north but we would get lake
effect snow which is like all the water
accumulates over the lake and then just
dumps on your city so I think this is a
big lake what like we're talking about
uh Lake Ontario so one of the great ones
right and like I think Buffalo got it
the worst because it would go over the
length of the lay of the lake but we
just got like the width of the lake
which was not as bad but they were like
Canada storms that would dump on us and
yeah we'd go to the lake house and fish
and do all that stuff so like ice
fishing we wouldn't wouldn't go in the
winter that much we would only go a
couple times I think we tried ice
fishing and then my dad decided it was
way too dangerous for little ones
usually cut the ice like it gets intense
yeah I'm not interested I don't like
being cold
I don't like fishing know what you don't
like fishing no I mean if you're called
fishing doesn't warm you up I don't like
waiting does it that's true you do out
that piece you know I'll do one of those
farms one of those fish for me I can't
miss give me a net and like give me a
pond full of salmon or something I'll be
happy to that okay what was there the
entertainment spirit kind of starting to
bubble up at that point class clown type
scenario or the net going on not at all
really no not at all so how were you how
how where I had worried you terrified of
Authority just wanted to go to school
and get homework done I wanted to make
my parents proud and
get out of Rochester was like my number
one goal just wanted to leave the
miserable town project and and why do
you want to leave him what did you think
you were going to go to well like when I
applied for colleges uh I brought my
list of schools into my counselor and he
like laughed and he was like these are
all safe schools I'm like yeah but you
don't understand all I want to do is
just go anywhere that's a city because
Rochester's so like nothing's happening
like we would party and like fields like
there's nothing going on bonfires yes
exactly and I just wanted a relatively
small school cuz I was I just wanted a
small class you know so that's all that
I really wanted and looking back I mean
Rochester's not a bad place it's a great
place but not for somebody that's like
itchy and wants city and hustle and
bustle so that's all I wanted and I got
into every school that I applied to and
I chose Suffolk and that's in Boston so
more of more of the same in college kind
of it's kind of like this the sequel of
high school for you you're not we're not
into this you becoming an entertainer
yet still right no I I never thought
that my life would be anything like this
like I had a different life plan you
know
College for me was very much like I
don't know the way that I was raised I
there's a lot of strong women that
surround me in my life and my family and
like who who do you mean well my mom's
sister she was an Emmy winner for
broadcast journalism um my other aunt
she's actually my grandma's sister she
worked in the Library of Congress for
years and years and years I don't know
what it's called but whatever the head
of copyright during like the Napster
years well she was in the library like
these people they don't take any from
anybody you know an attic that explains
why your most viral video has copy
written a song anyway like how does she
get away with that we got some never
gonna give you up under there I don't
know how to happen it will it's your
aunt she pulled some strings for you
you just gave us the answer you can deny
now but we know I really don't even know
that my aunt knows how to use YouTube
she's like I didn't want to derail you
from any from the strong women yeah yeah
for college I you know education was
really really really important to me and
that's why I went on to graduate school
because my education was not done you
know I got my bachelor's degree and it
was like um so I don't feel comfortable
being an adult I think you need to keep
learning some things so I put all my
eggs in one basket and I applied to one
graduate school because I was like if I
get in great and if I don't I'm not
going like they took thirteen people a
year and it was Boston University sports
psychology program because my identity
was so ingrained in this like sports and
that sort of thing it's so difficult to
let that part of you die like to ever
see a different part of your life you
can't imagine yourself without it like
Who am I I have no idea I've been doing
this my entire life so I chose sports
psychology and I got in and I one of 13
yeah a year just bananas and I got in
and I went and I met my advisor and I
would say really like I started getting
really goofy in college but not in any
sort of entertainment way but like grad
school and after grad school is when got
goofy like really goofy how so give us a
for instance
well I was a youngest person in my
graduate school program and I felt sort
of like I was I had my big girl pants on
I was trying to be like all these other
adults you know like mm-hmm like we're
gonna be professionals in our field and
blah blah blah
I felt like I was being myself but just
a really stuffy boring version of myself
I need to let my butterfly go so what
did that where did the butterfly go -
well I through a series of events wound
up working a bunch of part-time jobs
which was like a tanning salon
I was go-go dancing which is the best
part-time job ever
and I highly recommend it to anyone
explaining the mechanics of that so
you're dancing mechanics you're
basically hired either by a club or a
promoter or someone to come and like
dance on a stage or like a box or in a
cage like depending on the venue are you
doing stage boxer cakes now I think it's
worth noting that you weren't doing
sports psychology right no I was on so
okay so I've never worked in my field
but you got your degree though correct
you got your degree and then I mean we
kind of skipped over that what why
didn't you get a job in sports
psychology well I tried a friend of mine
wanted to move to Texas and I was down
because there's great sport psychology
jobs there especially in the military
like using biofeedback and things like
that and I was like you know what that
sounds great and then she bailed on me
like the last minute she was like you
know I'm not gonna move to Texas and at
that point I had like you know told my
landlord I'm moving out like she just
doesn't really understand the
consequences of things sometimes God
loved her so we didn't speak for like a
year like I was thoroughly convinced
that she had destroyed my life my
education like everything I had worked
for because there's not really a whole
lot of sports ecology jobs in Boston so
that was the fork in the road to tanni
salon and go-go dancer correct
I was putting food on my table keeping a
roof over my head at all costs because I
don't not that I have anything against
people that do this but it was ever an
option for me to be anything but
financially taking care of myself you
know like Oh Jenna you can move home was
never a conversation that anybody had
like it's just not a choice like you're
an adult figure it out so I really I
busted my ass so do whatever I could to
just feed myself and uh you know it's
not the most fun thing in the world when
you know you look at your degrees and
you you have nothing
show for it you have no job you're
literally cleaning people's sweat out of
a tanning bed while they treat you like
some big dumb blonde idiot at your job
and it's just infuriating you know what
I mean and I just felt like I had worked
so hard and it sort of got thrown away
for a lot of different reasons and it's
interesting because there's that scene
at the end of that first huge video
where you're like crying holding your
degrees yeah that it seems like that was
a very top of mind thing for a number of
years that I had this plan hmm I have
these degrees but it's not it's not
happening but at least I'm going to
embrace it for a comedy right in this
video so connect the dots to that first
video well I was working at a blog
called parcel sports comm and I was sort
of just as I started as a promo model
because you know inappropriate pictures
and then inappropriate dancing turns
into like you stand and hold like liquor
bottles and promote things for people so
I got a job as his promo model for the
owner Dave Portenoy and then so he saw
you go-go dancing
he found pictures of me and he was like
I had done a little bit of promo work in
the past and he was like oh can you fill
in last minute for this thing and I
never realized in this is gonna sound
terrible but like in the world of like
pretty girls that get paid to be pretty
girls just being on time and then not
being crazy is like a really big asset I
was like okay I can do this cuz you know
it's just whether they mean to or not
there's like people's boyfriends that
come in and they start a fight and
they're or they're just late or they
don't show up or then they don't they're
mean to customers and they don't talk
I'm like it's really not that hard like
you just gotta hug them and like make
sure that they're having a great time
like this is a great job like no am I
alone
I do think you have to be at least in
the right mindset in order to do that
you know what I mean like
know that it's your job to just stand
there and do stuff and and look cute and
make sure people are having fun
but then he called me one day and was
like do you want to be my assistant like
help me do stuff and I'm like be kidding
me
because it was you know one of the first
times I was gonna be able to have one
job like and not go to 20 jobs and not
work through the night every night and
then that turned into a writing gig at
the blog and he really helped me like
find my you know voice and that sort of
thing and what were you writing about it
started off as like a guest blog on his
blog so his blog is sports and hot girls
and viral web material and that sort of
thing and he was just having sort of
write little blogs about anything just
from a girl perspective and he came down
into my office one day it was like you
can write and I'm like what do you mean
I can't like I went to school I mean but
I guess that shocked him so yeah I got
to write for them for a little while and
one day I was going home from that job
from that office and I still needed to
go go dance later that night I was still
doing that because that was the most fun
of all my jobs and I genuinely enjoyed
it and I was like you know what I mean
like I'm tired of people introducing
themselves to me during the day and then
introducing themselves to me later that
night because they have no idea that I'm
the same person like I looked so
completely different and I understand
like the the gender norm that sort of
thing like that you're a girl and you
look a certain way and that means this
sort of thing or whatever but I very
much play into it I do that I put myself
in all this makeup and whatever to look
like a different person to do things
like in order to make a living right now
it's a joke it sucks I hate it you know
what I mean so I was like I'm just gonna
record myself getting ready and just
make it a video and like that was one of
the most confusing times of my life and
there's been many times since then and
since some other big videos like I'll
make something ridiculously funny that
people really respond to and one of the
weirdest like most confusing point
to my life and I'm like what does this
mean doesn't mean if I'm happy I can't
make good content like this sucks okay
so this in the video was just in case
you happen to not know what she's
talking about is that how to make
yourself yeah I treat people anything
you're good-looking and so you're saying
that during the day at that point in
your life you were not very made of you
know for the for the night job correct
and you made the video for what were you
watching youtube videos and you know I
can do that too what was that outlet
well in college I was using YouTube as a
way to bypass the fact that my computer
didn't have a CD burner on it but I
didn't realize that it was a like a
social media thing so I was uploading
just dumb videos that I could then send
the link to my friends or if it was a
school project that I could you know
access from the classroom instead of
burning his CDs I didn't have a CD
burner so it was a spring so for this
one I'm gonna make this video I'm gonna
put on YouTube to send to friends or yes
to send to friends the first thing I did
was put it on Facebook but you would she
had a but it was the jenna Marbles
channel name at that point right it
wasn't your first video
you had other videos and it was already
called jenna Marbles yeah I had another
channel before that it was called Jay
Maury 66 which is falling just bowling
yeah it's still alive there's stuff
there but yet people were like oh you
know she's only been in youtubers in
2009 I had another Channel I had to
change my last name because my mom was
yelling at me that it was ruining her
Google searches that I was using the
word Maury which is our real last name
she was like you got to change this
weird stuff you're putting on the
internet with your name like it's
ruining my Google searches I'm trying to
get a job which she was like switching
jobs at that point it was ruining
potential employers google searching her
her correct she was like if you search
Debra Maury like some of your stuff
comes up and I don't like it what are
you doing in those videos that she was
that she didn't like nothing really I
don't they
it was just like you know dumb stuff
with my dog or pictures of me at go-go
dancing or something where the it's just
not something you want an employer to
see so yeah and so you change it they
may hire your mom thinking they're great
one thing so so how did you come up with
jenna Marbles marbles is my dog's name
okay so marbles was the dog's name it
wasn't marbles his name dr. Jana Kermit
doesn't sound quite as good doesn't
Kermit came later people get mad about
that okay you don't show curtain eel of
my karma gets plenty of love okay relax
so you put the video up and you just put
it on Facebook for your friends and then
how quickly does this thing blow up well
by the time I got to my go-go dancing
job Lior that night people were like we
saw that I'm like oh I just posted it
like like I didn't even watch it after I
posted it like that's crazy and then
later that weekend I clicked on the
video Sunday morning and I saw that had
like 750,000 views and that's when I
started to get like hot in the face and
like oh my god this is more than my
friends like I don't know these people
this is pretty nerve-racking so I made
it a point to call my mom and I was like
mom I put something on here in it
I swore in it and a lot of people have
watched it and she's sort of like
nervously laughed like I don't think she
knew what to expect by that sentence and
I was like no I'll send it to you and
look at it and she just said the main
reason the whole I swore in it part was
that why you told her because you knew
she was gonna see it you didn't want her
to think you were swearing I don't know
I don't know I I was just sort of
telling her what it was the best that I
could just so she was prepared for the
words that came out of my mouth we
weren't really allowed to swear growing
up um so maybe that's why I like to
swear I feel like I'm getting away with
stuff but she watched it and she like
giggles and I'm like good we're all good
then we're we're great now because as
long as you laugh and think it's funny
then
I have no worries you know what I mean
so you got it straightened out with your
mom she was okay with it but what were
you thinking at the time I mean I
another week past and how many more
views came along and what and what was
you know it was a lot it was few million
I mean it by the end of that week and it
hit like a million which was like I
posted on a Friday night and it was like
Sunday it was like a million views so I
did I was like nervous and but I wanted
to just keep making videos because I
just had a lot of things in my head that
I wanted to make but I didn't know what
to do like you can't wrap your head
around a million views when that happens
you're like what does this mean now what
do you mean a million people like I
think the most people I've ever seen my
life is like fifty thousand Bruno and
then your brains just like what what
what is this I don't know and and it's
also you know having talked a lot of
people here on your biscuits who all of
a sudden they're there YouTube stardom
kind of just was was overnight yeah you
know you have different stories there
might be someone who was trying over and
over and over again and one thing popped
for you it was kind of like oh I've got
this idea this is my outlet all posted
for my friends and then that we can it
gets a million views what kinds of
things were running through your head in
terms of is this life changing were you
thinking things like that well no I
wasn't thinking about if it was life
changing because at that point I was so
working for the blog I was working for
parcels forts and his reaction to the
video he put it on his website and his
reaction to that was well you know
you're let's give you your own blog like
let's give you a girl version of this
blog and you know I was sort of confused
like well don't you think I should just
make more videos like that would be cool
right
and he's like no you can do that all you
want but I want you to write a girl
version of our blog
and so I did and I thought it was gonna
be great and fun and it was for a while
but it just didn't have the traction
behind it the way that the video had and
so at that point he'd redirected you you
didn't make another video I like made a
couple but I was you know took maybe six
months off from making content after
that first video six months something
like that because I was writing the girl
version of his blog for about six months
and it's you know it's not a good
financial investment for him to keep
funneling money into my website that's
not getting millions and millions of
views like he had hoped off of this
video so we started parted ways and then
I was he telling you not to do another
video
oh no you were just too busy I was busy
blogging it to any blogger in the world
that thing is a full-time job
oh my god like oh just never ends
non-stop when you wanted them in but you
didn't want to do that you wanted to
make more videos you guys parted ways
and then you started doing it back up
again did were you surprised at the
audience that you started to gather
around you yes in what way I did not
know how young they were what we yeah
what did you think and how did you
figure out who it was well coming from
the blogging background which was the
demographic was the older drinking of
drinking age mail so those are the
people that had followed me to YouTube
but then the other people that were
watching me I was like how old are you
like this doesn't make any sense
like you'd click on someone's channel
that had commented on your video
annually but you're like 13 like I swore
I like drinking this video like what do
you mean you can watch this like wearing
parents but totally not the point
because kids can watch whatever they
want and they do I was surprised that
they were young and that they were
identifying with what I was saying
because I've never really tried to
address being a teenager or like being a
young person when I've talked about some
of those topics but I don't like make
them for teenagers but when you found
out that you did have a large teenage
and very large female
the majority yes did that change
anything about the way you thought about
your content no if anything it just felt
like more fun because when you're
performing like a thing and you think or
know that the opposite sex is watching
sometimes it gets a little nerve-racking
you're like well this makes me
uncomfortable
but when you know it's like 13 old girls
you're like in the trust tree in the
nest like these are my boo-boos these
are my internet friends like all they
want to do is like talk to you and be
your friend and it felt really really
really good it was a much more
satisfying feeling to me to know that my
audience was female girls as opposed to
25 year old men you know what I mean
like if you knew that your I wasn't as
creepy it wasn't as creepy and it felt
like there was way less pressure
honestly but you also said that you know
your initial reaction was whoa I I was
swearing and I was drinking in the
videos that was your first thought it
was kind of like going back to the mom
thing where you - mom I swore in this
video right it seems that you were at
the same time kind of having that that
reaction to these younger girls watching
your video but it did that didn't
translate into you change you altering
your content right so what was kind of
going on your mind at that point it
seemed like there was there had have
been a decision to be made what do you
mean to not change my content yeah
well honestly you were surprised I was
surprised but what I liked about it was
that I was staying true to myself and
someone you know like that seemed may be
too young to me could get something out
of it of value so Who am I to say that
you're too young to be watching this and
that because the people that are
watching me are of a certain age that I
should do something different or more
appropriate like it's not my place if
you want to watch my video that's your
thing and if they take something from
that that maybe a parent would feel is
inappropriate then they're gonna get
that information or material somewhere
else like it really doesn't matter but I
can only be myself I can't talk about
things that don't matter to me
and you know making fake content that I
think that someone would wanna watch
just feels ridiculously fake and stupid
to me how do you do you think that that
perspective and you know that
authenticity that you bring to it is the
reason that you're the number one female
on on YouTube and I and in the top you
know three of everyone I don't know I
have no idea why my channel is where it
is I it's an incredible amount of luck
and a lot of it's like a recipe of a lot
of things that happen
I like to think that maybe it's because
people can relate to me and I can only
keep it real you know what I mean I
can't I can't do brand deals I can't do
like the super fake collaborations not
that there's anything wrong with the
people that can successfully do those I
just can't force something you know I
mean I can only say true to myself and
when when people you know stuff in their
pockets with money for these brand deals
I'm like I can't do it it doesn't feel
right I would literally sit on the
screen and be like drink such and such
product because they're paying me and
I'm like sucking my soul out right now
I'm sorry like it would be the fakest
promotion you've ever seen in your life
I just can't I can't do it I can't so I
I hope that people think that I'm
genuine because I am you get any of
those people approached you for brand
deals you don't do them just sentiment
to us it never gets easy to say no
though it never does because I always
want to say yes well I'm a terrible liar
but you know and I do think that there
is a and I'm not and this is not to
defend guys like us who do a lot of
brand deals but I do think there's a
there's a difference in your content
because agreed your content is is is
this is kind of a - it's an observation
in a question your content is is you
right right so we do content that is us
but we do a lot of contents that's
performance based or scripted or music
videos or whatever and sponsorship kind
of feels a little bit different in that
context yeah but you know I think that
when your content is so much you when
you're a vlogger yeah people are coming
to you they're coming for you so if you
don't know you say it's a recipe of a
lot of different things but what it what
do you think people are coming back for
because they're coming back for
something and they keep coming back
because you obviously you're not a flash
in the pan you weren't one viral video
you're in this you've been in this for a
long time with no signs of slowing down
I mean what what did people coming back
for beats me
it beats me all I know is that when I
meet people in person its we have like a
it's a connection you know what I mean
they feel like they know me and they do
know a lot of me they know everything
that I'm willing to put on camera which
is a lot and I'm I'm more than happy to
hug and spend time with anybody that
feels that connection with me and I
always feel it back always like they
literally just want to have a
conversation with you
and that's it and that makes them very
happy and that makes me very happy so I
think it might be the fact that these
people you don't really feel like they
know me and it's because they they do a
lot mm-hmm
you know like they're they've grown up
with me a lot I've grown up in a lot of
ways yes so your audience you give them
the real you they know you they have
that connection but it is there a sense
of isolation when you become as popular
as you are I mean maybe on a on a
personal level for sure absolutely I
mean it's a lot it's like something that
a lot of people don't really talk about
how lonely it is when you work alone in
your house all the time and that's why I
was late today and thank you very much
for letting me be late because one of
the only things that I do is leave the
house to go lift really heavy stuff
every day and it's really important to
me because you're like work for a moving
company like deadlifts like push-ups and
stuff
it's really really important to me for
my sanity to make sure that I get out of
the house once a day and to make sure
that I make human real contact with
other people every day and you know it's
really easy to not take care of yourself
I like to go a little bit crazy to have
like weird internet hours which always
turns into like the dark internet corner
hours or like 2:00 in the morning
because I don't I'm not married don't
have kids like I don't have this sort of
like innate family structure it's like
me so like when you're depending on
yourself to sort of like create your
life sometimes you're just like yeah
whatever we're just gonna do anything
that I want and then it just you don't
have any structure right you know my
Wednesday videos keep me honest but then
the rest of it is sort of just like when
my brain allows me to like put myself
out there I put myself out there but it
is lonely and I'm not sure if it has
anything to do with the level of
popularity because I felt just as lonely
and isolated in Boston when I lived
there I moved out here like two three
years ago three years ago I think
because I sort of thought like oh well
here's all these people that do the same
thing as me and I'm alone in Boston and
everybody works in finance and doesn't
understand what I do but but but now
doing this even your closest
relationships by default become the most
public yes you know I mean you went
through a very public breakup I did and
so I mean what you're not that public
it's not like the whole time awful yeah
I mean but people did know that that was
the thing because because you got you
you had a relationship you guys were in
each other's videos and I mean it was
then when that ended there was I mean
there were there were tweets flying back
and forth you're telling us okay I don't
have a lot of people in my life
personally and then when the closest
people are on display yes it's very very
hard so I mean when it with the max
situation how did you deal with that how
did that feel you want the honest answer
of course we're gonna go there all right
this is ear biscuit
when Max and I broke up it was like I'm
sure max is gonna kill me if he ever
hears this because I'm not I know no he
wouldn't
we're in a good place now but our
breakup was like a long time coming it
we had like we met each other when I was
21 and he was like 22 and it started off
on the wrong foot we didn't really trust
he was dating everyone and I was dating
another guy and you know we just sort of
started this like fling level like sure
whatever you're cool you're cool like I
like you I like you and then a couple
years later we like moved in together it
was like a very adult relationship and
we moved to LA together and he quit his
job for me he worked in real estate
development and he was really good at it
and he has this great education and a
great family and I think you know I
can't speak for them but I imagine
they're sort of like well what are you
doing like why are you quitting this
great job that you've worked so hard for
and it was because we're in love and
blah blah blah but and he was with you
before during and after the yeah we were
really like almost 5 years so he was
there with me through everything like he
was my rock you know and we moved to LA
and he started just helped me and you
know as anyone would it's sort of like
well why do you get to have this cool
life and I'm just over here like helping
you like this doesn't make any sense
and Max is more than smart and capable
and funny and he was a great sounding
board for me to balance ideas off of
but in our personal relationship like we
had a lot of issues that never just
never got resolved from when we started
and there's a lot of hurt like a lot of
distrust a lot of pain
and it was so frustrating to me to look
back and see some of like my best
content came out of his time and I was
like so sad like really sad really
really in love but we just had sort of
like a bad romance at the time you know
and it needed to end one way or another
and it ended and I got obliterated drunk
for two weeks straight long story short
the way that I dealt with that was
incredibly immature but it was like I
really felt like I just could not be in
my brain space and I woke up after two
weeks basically of just being an idiot I
I was like on chatroulette like hit my
friends like yeah we just got can you
come over man like let's hang out I
gotta get drunk and I woke up and I was
like what am i doing like something
terrible is gonna happen to me if I keep
doing this like I have to pull myself
together you know but I had uploaded
like a video of extras like I was trying
anything because when you have this like
horrible hole in your heart you're like
how in the world can I possibly be funny
at this moment I can't be entertaining I
can't think about anything other than
just trying to make it through the day
so you didn't upload any videos you you
tried to republish some extra content to
keep I did your fans at bay I did i sat
in the video I didn't address it
immediately I dress it about a month
later when I told people that we had
broken up because I needed to give
myself like at least a month to calm
down from like saying anything that I
would really regret or that would hurt
me or hurt him because it's he had
started making YouTube videos at that
point right so you know I had never
dated someone that did something that
wasn't like a regular person job like
you know if you break up then you break
up and or whatever but this was the
first time that I was like I can't say
something all I have is my voice and my
genuineness and I can't I just need to
for my own sake and for his sake just be
quiet for a little bit and it's really
for me to be quiet but that was really
really hard for me to just address my
audience and say you know I'm I don't I
don't feel good this week and I I'm
really sorry I just got to put up some
extras and I didn't say what it was
about that was really really difficult
well an interesting thing about that too
is that there there are a lot of
vloggers who will share about new
relationships existing relationships
ended relationships now that a lot of
times is a very entertaining and you are
very entertaining and I think you you
think about your audience so you weren't
like you know what I'm going through
this very difficult time I'm gonna
leverage this for content that will be
connecting to my audience because what I
hear kind of underneath all that is the
mentality is I'm really here to
entertain my audience not not that
you're putting on a show for them you're
being authentic but you are performing
in one sense I mean you're a comedian
right and so you're like I don't have
the comedy is not coming because of what
I'm going through right now as opposed
to actually making a video about the
break-up talk about that process do you
think it's do you think it's just the
generation that you're from you know
maybe if you were 17
you would you would have blocked vlog
about that or I guess maybe I mean I
can't say for sure but all I do know is
that had I experienced any of this
YouTube or internet thing at a younger
age then my phone jeez that's not my
ring I'm not sure that I would be able
to handle something like that I feel
like because I started as an adult and
I'm still an adult that I can handle
sort of like thinking about this in an
appropriate way like what's an
appropriate way to do this
not that 17 and you know we just broke
up and I hate this person whenever not
that that's inappropriate I just think
that maybe as an adult I didn't see that
as an option you know what I mean right
it just didn't it didn't feel right I
didn't want to and it's only been as of
like recently I guess I've even you know
said anything about it because
I had put max out there and max put
himself out there because I was out
there and he saw how incredibly
rewarding and amazing it can be so he
wanted to but you did make a decision at
some point to let him have it in a
couple of tweets I did I did I did I was
mad that day and that but that was later
it was it was much later it was much
later I was really really mad that day
well based on what you tweeted it sounds
like you know that you were justified
but I mean I'm just reading a couple of
tweets I don't know the whole story I
don't I don't I don't think it's not
that I want you to go into the rest of
the story
I just found it interesting that you
know you kind of had this okay I'm gonna
be professional about this we're just
parting ways but then there's this you
gave him one last I did jab I did and if
you ask him that's not what happened um
but it's a gray area
it's a gray area of what happened there
and what I said and when he says but I
mean there's two people in a
relationship and I guess this one
particular thing or lots of things or
anything
I felt very differently about and I felt
strongly about and I was very angry in
the past I guess I've let it go at this
point but I was angry at the fact that
you know he had a youtube channel I was
like what the hell you didn't figure out
your life you figured out my life like
that's not fair but I've stuck back from
that because max has a lot to offer as a
human being because I mean I was in love
with a kid for five years still in love
with him will always be in love with him
but like who am I to say that you can't
be on the internet or that that should
make me mad because that's a very
childish thing to do because I have
always thought there's enough room on
the internet for everyone like everyone
everyone has a place anyone can just do
a thing and how that'd be awesome like
it was stupid of me to even be mad about
that I was very very mad for a long time
but I'm in a better place
well let's talk about let's talk about
the better place date that you're at
right now kind of time back into this
this idea of moving out to LA thinking
that okay maybe I'm gonna be a part of
this community sounds like that didn't
necessarily pan out it wasn't like all
of a sudden you had a bunch of friends
who were youtubers or whatever you you
were in a relationship with max that
ended and then now you're in another
relationship I guess I've never admitted
that but yes yes it and that wasn't that
wasn't somebody you met it uh that
wasn't a youtuber you met at a YouTube
party no no no it's not he's uh tell us
about Julian oh my god you guys it's so
embarrassing I mean he's in your videos
very very very awesome how did you guys
meet Julian worked at the bar up the
street from my house and Max and I
actually met him while we were together
oh really so max is not very fond of
Julian I don't think I don't think
Julian's very fond max but we're all
adults but Julian's freaking awesome
he's really really awesome and um he was
there for me for a lot of things and so
I'm very grateful so I mean are you
guarded now because of the whole max
thing being on display is I mean I guess
that's what's behind you being so
guarded at this point but there's only
so much you can do you are on display I
mean this is difficult I know it well
here's the thing is that I'm more
guarded for the people that watch my
videos than I am about myself
I'm obviously willing to put myself out
there max was to some extent so it was
Julian it's not me that I'm concerned
about
it's the the people that get so attached
to this person
then they are very upset about us
breaking up yeah so I want to make sure
because it's not something that's safe
for me to assume because I'm willing to
put myself out there that anyone that
I'm with is willing to be put out there
because you know my family and that sort
of thing friends like they're not all
comfortable being in a vlog or being in
an Instagram picture they don't we don't
put our wives in our video not everyone
wants to be out there so I try to be
mindful of that and I also want to test
a relationship to a certain point where
if someone's comfortable with it and
they want to then oh you can do whatever
you want you can be in here am I going
to openly promote someone the way that I
did with max maybe not maybe I would
have learned my lesson from that much
but people know who Julian is people
know that we've been dating I just try
and be careful I guess for other people
and for the person that I'm dating you
know right you're trying to make it as
uncomplicated as as a relationship can
be correct speaking of being guarded I
was just curious in terms of video
content is there something you've ever
regretted talking about or doing oh well
I did make the you know quote-unquote
slut-shaming video people were very
upset about I don't regret anything but
I wish I had done a better job
explaining what tell us about that video
and just kind of summarize the content
well my goal in making that video was I
mean as you guys know a lot of times you
get reminded that you have social
responsibility to these people that
watch your videos you can't just like
you know do whatever you want and then
have not some like a bunch of people be
like you have an audience like you have
a platform like why aren't you doing
anything to help people and I really
wanted to make that video because I was
just I felt very saturated and have my
entire life with this like sexy sex
thing going on and then it's really cool
to just like be sexually liberated and I
wish I had put a disclaimer on that
video like if you
you know college and above or high
school and above and you're very
comfortable your sexuality like please
go do that like I'm not trying to shame
anyone that is an adult and knows like
how they feel about their body and other
people's bodies and that sort of thing I
was making it more so for the young
girls that you know are told on a
regular basis like it's really cool to
just sleep around and do whatever you
want and just have coochie and ass and
it's all over the place
what's the video called uh things I
don't understand about girls the [ __ ]
edition people have a problem with that
word and I defined it in the beginning
is not not the girl that's like you know
sleeps a lot of people or that girl's
really confused it's just the girl where
you're just like oh yeah I know who
you're talking about and people are very
they're mad at that but that's in my
brain that's what that is and it's
ironic to me that I imagine you get a
lot of criticism for not taking
advantage of your your platform and
being a positive influence on young
women and it seems like that this was
your video where you were trying to do
that I was taken it went horribly wrong
it was awful
I literally I got crucified for saying
the words I did in that video people
took that as me victim blaming and
saying that if you get raped or an STD
that it's your fault I mean I was just
so taken aback at the things that people
responded to that and hurt and upset and
it's totally I will not delete a video
just on principle but I was so upset
that that's what people left that video
feeling because what I wanted people to
hear because I try and be entertaining
trying to talk about something that is
important to me
to just give the message that I think
monogamy is cool and you know if you're
a 13 year old girl and we're having
honors conversation around a dinner
table that I think that you're cool if
you like one person and you don't have
sex with a lot of people just because I
know that you get told that by your
friends and by people that you look up
to on a regular basis and just that I
think that you're cool just the way that
you are
if you like one person I'm down with
that I like that like cool good for you
so did you make a follow-up video where
you just kind of looked it in I never
did because I I was just so appalled and
the response videos of people telling me
that I was victim shaming and [ __ ]
blaming and all of this nonsense and the
the underlying theme of that was to just
I think that it's cool to do like
relationships that make sense that you
have emotional feelings behind and that
girls should look out for each other
like that was the other thing that
people just totally glazed over like I
described the scene where I've seen so
many times where a girl is sort of just
like drunken in the corner of a party
like you can't see you don't know where
her friends are maybe we've been
watching her for a little bit she's like
passed out on the couch like go help
that girl go help that girl be that
person it doesn't matter that you're a
stranger you're another girl at least
you're not a dude and no offense to you
dudes but like I would just feel so much
more comfortable if I was in that
situation and a girl came up to me and
was like let me help you
but because you know girls as creatures
we sort of have this like ruffle your
feathers like girl competition sometimes
I feel like there's a lack of that
there's a lack of the empathy for the
drunk girl in the corner that needs help
and doesn't know where her friends are
what did that response things didn't go
the way that you anticipated them to go
did that make you hesitant to make
videos that have quote-unquote a moral
to the story sure yeah I mean I
definitely thought about it for a little
bit and I'm not sure that I've gone into
depth especially in that topic I'm gonna
stay off that for a little bit because
it's clearly a hot-button topic for
people but I feel the way that I feel
about it and I don't take back what I
said I I'm extremely upset and
apologetic for the way that people took
it that was certainly not my intention
ever but I I'm going to say what I'm
gonna say and I'm gonna keep making
content that is true to me whether or
not people agree with that but I was
upset that people took it the way that
they did for sure it sucks you know I
also wanted to ask you about a year ago
The Good Morning America
give that lady that I actually feel a
little bad no because I took us on
cecilia Vega tell you that much and how
did you do that I mean how would you
characterize the interview first because
I know that you know Hank green came to
your defense yes an article yeah how he
characterized the interview when I went
in that interview right we sat down had
like a really honest conversation like
we're having right now and it seemed
like it was gonna be a totally different
outcome you know you just she had a lot
of questions that made sense and sounded
like she had done some homework and you
know wasn't just sort of being a jerk
and then the piece came out and she just
had edited the entire thing that I was
like ridiculous and ridiculous I'm
ridiculous it's I ridiculous and I was
like I can't believe I sat down with
that woman and talked to her and like
said anything of value to her because if
I knew she was gonna do that I would
just sit there and give her the finger
the entire time you know and so I was I
was very appreciative of the support
from the YouTube community because oh
how do you mean would how would you say
that it made you look I mean for those
who haven't seen it just to characterize
it in that way when you know they edited
you know the one question I wish I had
counted how many times you've said
ridiculous and then they did a montage
of it yes yes I mean you watching that
say oh they made me out to be what I
don't know ridiculous but I'm not scared
of you know sort of traditional media
painting you out to be this like
underground troll that like does things
on the internet because anyone that's
watching Good Morning America is not on
the internet so they don't really care
they're like good to know cecilia Vega
thank you
but anyone that knows how to use the
internet was like okay that was kind of
backhanded too like what the heck so and
so but how did you respond you said you
took a donor I did I wrote a blog that
was like you know this is the perfect
example
traditional media not really
understanding how people consume content
or want to I don't know live their lives
because she was rude and I didn't
appreciate it so I told her that the
Internet's not going anywhere and you
basically and was there ever any
response no but she did stop tweeting
for like a bunch of weeks and I was like
sick like you she probably got hammered
on Twitter I think she got in trouble a
little bit but um yeah sure I'm pretty
sure she's fine now just I think she'll
stay away from youtubers right well an
interesting thing we were talking about
this is and this is always the case and
it just it always drives me crazy but
the the introduction of the of the piece
was jenna Marbles the most famous person
you've never heard it and it's just
that's I I don't know why traditional
media continues to refer to anyone who
is popular in any other medium other
than a traditional one in that way or
you know we don't know you don't we're
introducing you to this YouTube
celebrity correct but I find it ironic I
got a little anecdotal evidence here and
this won't be surprising anybody listens
to ear biscuits but I just thought in
light of seeing that the way they
portrayed you on good mythical morning
oh good good sorry you should be a guest
right over there was I when we were
coming back from playlist and you were
on the same plane with us and I don't
even know the guys name the guy who
plays Scotty in Star Trek so you know a
blockbuster movie that lots of people
have seen he's also in Lord of the Rings
yeah yeah right he was one of those
horse dudes yeah so he's sitting there
in the airport no one no one is talking
to him no one recognizes him and then
here comes jenna Marbles and there's
like this I guess there were
cheerleaders from somewhere around yeah
anyway like 3040 girls all of a sudden
there's jenna mourey jennamarbles and
and I just thought isn't that just a
perfect picture of the reality the
reality here in the airport is that
everybody is is once I go talk to Jenna
and no one's talking to Scotty from Star
Trek but on Good Morning America and
we're talking about the new Star Trek
the overweight guy with a mustache but
in traditional media you're just the
person that no one's ever heard of how
does that when you when you saw that you
were obviously thinking about a lot of
different things but you probably have
done a lot of interviews and you've
talked to a lot of people in these
traditional circles and how do you kind
of deal with that perception that oh I
am that person from the underground that
thing you don't know about
I just don't I go in sort of assuming
that they don't they don't know who I am
they're sort of just doing it because I
was telling them to and a lot of times
that is the case but I just try and not
care because if they don't get it it's
not really my problem I mean it's not
really my problem that is 2014 and you
don't know how the internet works like I
think you got some other issues coming
like you better figure out that internet
dick well do you do you feel do you feel
like do you ever find yourself thinking
maybe not you want to prove something to
those people or you know we talked to we
talked on lots of people who are
probably on the internet but they almost
always are like well yeah but I want to
do this yeah I do want to do the jenna
Marbles movie or the jenna Marbles
TV show do you do you find yourself
thinking that yeah you know I am more
than I am more than just a someone
talked into our webcam I do want to do
this this and this do you put that kind
of pressure on yourself no I don't I
have no idea what I want to do can I
tell you how ridiculously like out of
place I feel sometimes around these
incredible other youtubers that have the
most amazing ideas and every like will
and way to do it like they will do like
Michael Gallagher like the Tobii like
these people are insane like they have
so many ideas if you sit down with
Hannah Hart at any given moment she has
10 million ideas and I am just not one
of those people I just sort of go with
the flow I don't have like
this list of goals I don't have things
that I'm trying to do or want to do I'm
just like a where the wind blows me so I
am not sure that I have anything to
prove or that I like I'm consciously
ever thinking that I'm just like I'm so
happy just being like a person that's
alive in the universe and yeah I'm just
sort of like going wherever this goes
and if it goes somewhere really cool not
that this isn't really cool because it's
really cool if it goes somewhere else
like I'm down to go there you know so no
I don't have anything approve and I
don't have any ideas yes oh my god when
I first started and it was like Joe
Penna like mr. guitar man and you know
you look at his channel and you're like
what the hell like what am i doing like
he just did like a stop motion like it
the most insane thing I've ever seen am
like well I guess I'm just gonna show my
cat Peter now it's just crazy it scares
me that you know I'm not a daily vlogger
these people that work these insane
hours all decay which you work like 20
hours of day every day all the time
that's insane I could scare sometimes
I'm like what am i doing enough like
what are we doing I don't know and the
only way I've been able to come to peace
with that it's just like you can't
compare yourself to other people's work
and what other people are doing you just
have to do what feels right to you so
that's what I do but it is intimidating
well yeah I mean you say in your draw my
life video that you have to be confused
in life or you won't grow it's true it's
true and I'm confused all the time
all the time I don't know why people
just think like I don't know I guess you
could consider it like I got good at
YouTube I got better at YouTube than it
was so if you get good dirt at something
then you like must know what you're
doing I don't know what I'm doing all I
know is that I just upload every week
and just do that I just try to make
things in my brain exists but I don't
know what I'm doing well I mean and
since you made that statement into all
my life you gain five million
subscribers over the
the next year so it it's still working
what do you hope that anyone listening
to this ear biscuit has learned or has
changed their mind about you oh geez um
I guess that do you have a sense of that
you know that you kind of choose your
words you figure out how you're gonna
present yourself because people want to
judge you um I never know how to choose
my words because I don't know how
they're coming out of my mouth when
they're coming out but I don't know if
there's anything if you think people
should take or would maybe take is that
you know when you're really excited and
uppity on the internet and doing really
goofy stuff that's not you all the time
like I can't tell you how many people
come up to me or like Oh Ryan Higa or
anybody that's just like oh like
thinking of one of your guys is like
really funny hilarious songs and things
like that and they're like well you know
I thought you'd be more like crazy and
out of control and you're like no
there's a time and a place for that yeah
and when you're doing that then you're
like that but like if you're walking
around like that 24/7 you're the most
obnoxious person on the planet you know
what I mean what I would hope people
would take away from this are any time
that you're talking honestly around a
table and microphones is that sometimes
you just need to like be a human being
and let's all be human beings sometimes
you know like who can go to bed while
they're sleeping and they like Disney
like Jenna
throw in a Disney here and there well we
appreciate the time it's been great to
get to know you now yeah you've got to
sign the roundtable of deadlines
[Music]
and that was the Jenna Marbles ear
biscuit we think about that link that
was that was an experience that was
experience for us because not only did
we talk to the most popular youtuber we
ever talked to but it was someone who we
had only met in passing like said hey to
like one time yeah and then the entire
everything that we know personally about
jenna Marbles that doesn't come from her
videos just happened at the roundtable
of dim lighting and she was real right
here it was the real Jenna yeah and
that's the thing that I think the main
thing that I noted is that it was just
like observing someone who is so
naturally talented and suited for
YouTube it's like what she does what she
brings to YouTube that has become so
immensely popular is something that when
you sit down on your meter in person you
see how she is just being herself and
herself is what makes her so big on
YouTube being being who she is she
wasn't in performance mode I think
watching having heard her in her own
words for this past hour plus watching
her videos it clicks even more that she
is authentically being naturally the
comedian that she just is right that
authenticity is perfectly suited for
astronomical success on YouTube right
it's like you know again I I try to
resist doing this but I can't I'm
fascinated when I think about just the
people who've been at this table to talk
to us and I would just make these
incredible observations about these
amazing people you were incredible
reservations about incredible any better
mediocre observations about incredible
people okay that's the more accept and
we always talk about how there is this
tenacity people have tried all these
different things and you see that with
Jenna she did she had she does have a
tenacity and you cannot be in this
business without a tenacity and this and
this approach but the the fact that it
is that this is a natural thing to her
she wasn't someone who sat around and
like schemed
try to figure out how to make things
work on YouTube she was just like I'm
gonna do what makes sense to me
right that webcam and those jump cuts
perfectly placed are the natural habitat
for her comedic instant it wasn't like
just okay oh yeah my lisa says it was
like no this is this is something that
is just skyrocketed to the top of
YouTube and just camped camped out there
I mean as long as anybody really you
know and you know I just think it was
fun it was a it was fun for me
personally I think there I don't know
how much people might have picked up on
it but there's a different tone when I
feel like we're like we're learning a
whole lot in the process because it's
like I've been familiar with their
content but I just haven't known her
personally and so my mind was just kind
of going through all these things like
man it's like this the experiences that
add up to who this woman is and how that
plays out on YouTube she's fascinating
you had a fascinated tone yes you did
yeah it's could you hear it in my voice
I could hear the fascination and I hope
that you at home were also fascinated on
your car or wherever you were being ear
biscuit it you've been here biscuit but
Jenna Mari you gotta go you're gonna go
by the real name well we've we've had
some quality time okay all right I just
messed up her mom's googling I still
don't understand I don't think our mama
understands how Google works well I mean
you know I understood my dad has never
contacted me and said listen man you
know people are searching for another
McLoughlin on the internet and it's
messing up my prospects we have a
different first name well we we can have
Jenna back and that can be the person
the next year biscuit is just know she
could bring her mom are okay you know we
can you know what that's where we could
start doing we could start bringing
parents of youtubers own well it may get
to that we could call it like ear
oatmeal or something like that your
fiber its ear fiber we only speak to the
parents of youtubers I think our
grandparents there's nothing
well this is like a fine brothers thing
we try we find different people to bring
in and different ways to divide up the
idea yeah here biscuits ear oatmeal and
ear fiber thanks for hanging out with us
and Jenna for this ear biscuit as always
you should tweet at Jenna and let her
know what you thought of this also we
appreciate you guys leaving a review on
iTunes that helps us and the ear biscuit
you can also leave a comment on
Soundcloud and communicate with us via
Twitter with hashtag ear biscuits and if
you're one of those people that
communicates via smoke signal I'm gonna
say that you can hear you loud you can
hear you can represent ear biscuits with
doing seven little bursts of smoke and
then like three additional burst of
smoke for like a five minute pause in
between the two and that'll be like our
little thing with it oh yeah your
biscuits the key is getting other people
to understand that's what you're talking
about they would have to actually listen
to the show to kind of defeat the
purpose so for all you smoke cigarettes
out there thanks things for your help in
promoting the show
[Music]
[Music]